Speaker 1: next example. The Q and on star Kirsten
Weldon, who said only idiots get vaccinated.
Is dead of COVID. It's we're now getting multiple
ones a day. Kirsten Weldon told her fans not to
get vaccinated wanted Dr. Foushee killed. She
believed he should be executed. She is dead of
COVID. A leading QAnon promoter who urged both her
followers and strangers she passed on the street
not to get vaccinated died Thursday of the virus.
She amassed tens of thousands of followers on
right wing media by promoting the pro-Trump
QAnon conspiracy under the name Kirsten W..
Weldon focused on attacking vaccines
and other efforts to fight COVID,
saying in one video that Dr. Anthony Fauci needs
to be hung from a rope. She claimed the vaccine
killed people and even recorded herself yelling
at people standing in line to get vaccinated. The
vaccines kill. Don't get it. This is how gullible
these idiots are. They're all getting the vaccine.
In December, Weldon started showing symptoms of
the virus. On December 28th, Weldon struggled
through remarks about the coming overthrow of the
government. Coughing and saying she was exhausted.
Three days later, she found herself in a hospital,
posted a picture wearing an oxygen mask, claiming
she had bacterial pneumonia. She wrote she
refused to take coronavirus treatment remdesivir,
calling it Dr. Fauci's ResMed Servier, misspelling
it. This is the latest instance of a far right
personality who opposed vaccination killed by
the virus. I just told you about Doug Kuzma,
who also died in the same way we've
previously talked about Robert David Steele.
We talked about Veronica Walorski, a Q and
on follower who is hospitalized with the
virus. People started calling in saying, give
her ivermectin. She died later that month.
What is there to say at this point? I mean, do we
have sympathy? My audience is mixed on this. I,
whenever I do a story like this, some of you
write to me and you say, I have no sympathy.
They didn't get vaccinated, et cetera. They
are perpetrators. They are also victims.
I mean, if you fall for this stuff in some
way, you are a victim of disinformation,
it's a it's an empirical reality.
You've fallen for misinformation.
You didn't create it. You've fallen for it.
And at the same time, you are a perpetrator
because you encourage others to do the same. And
who knows how many people got sick as a result
of either of these individuals. So
I know my audience is mixed on this.
But at this point in time, given the level of
contagion of Akron and how easily it spreads,
the vaccine is increasingly to protect yourself.
Would these individuals have survived if they had
had three doses? Statistically, it's likely,
you know, you can't draw a conclusion about
an individual. Doug Kuzma with his bronchial
condition and the weight he might have died.
Either way, we don't know statistically. He would
have had a dramatically reduced shot at dying if
he had had three doses, of course. Same same with
with Kirsten Weldon here as well. So I continue to
welcome your thoughts about what should be our
view about things like this. But get yourselves
vaccinated. My family lost an additional person
over the weekend. My my dad's cousin in Argentina
vaccinated initially down there. They had
the Russian and Chinese vaccines. I don't
know exactly which one he had, but vaccinated
to some degree, had preexisting conditions
came down with the virus. Unclear where he got
it ended up being sedated on a ventilator for
three weeks. Developed infections developed kidney
issues. Horrible, horrible, horrible. Devastating
to the family, and he died over the weekend. And
if you have an opportunity to get vaccinated,
take it because that's the fate afflicting
disproportionately unvaccinated people. My
dad's cousin had preexisting conditions, there's
no doubt about it, but he was not particularly
old and it got him. Why? Why not wear the suit
of armor if you're walking through the forest
of arrows? Why not wear the seatbelt? If you're
driving, you might never need it, but you might.
And I am convinced we are going to see more
and more stories like this continue to come in.